pounding the pavements of
bolton the military on a deployment of
surveillance and testing in one of the
worst hit areas by the so-called
indian variant to halt its spread
people see a uniform a bit startled
straight away but as soon as we
describe what we're doing they're more
than willing to assist us next door to
another hot spot in west london the
nation's home of rugby
is playing its part in another national
effort a tournament this time
between the vaccine and the virus all
the while
june the 21st fast approaches
kira is back from university and taking
advantage of the one day only
vaccination facility
for anyone over the age of 18. i think
the main thing is seeing the people that
you love and like we can do that now and
that's like
what was most important and like best
for our mental health so yeah
if it was delayed by a couple of weeks
that would be fine with me yeah i'm just
happy to be able to see people right now
the final big unlocking would mean that
in just over 20 days time i will be able
to sit in this stadium with
tens of thousands of people if there's
any chance of that being able to happen
then the success of the vaccination
program needs to continue
particularly in areas of concern
june the 21st would bring an end to
every rule we've come to live with over
the past year
but some senior scientists say it's
frighteningly optimistic
in a way i think the dates all the way
through were were created just to give
everybody some kind of sense of
structure but they were always qualified
uh as being based on what actually
happened
and that they could change and i think
there's a
significant chance that it could change
if we wake up in july
saying we made a terrible error it will
have been
because we didn't uh go cautiously
enough
currently on the government's roadmap
the scrapping of social distancing
and losing the rule of six indoors it
means for the hospitality industry
there's a lot on the line for smaller
venues the eradication of all
restrictions
is high on their wish list for a lot of
the high street pubs which haven't got
outside space
um it's going to be really difficult
obviously they're going to lose their
capacity they're
probably a lot of them trading about 50
capacity so obviously
for us it's not a problem pubs with
outside areas but for the ones that got
um
no outside space it's gonna be really
difficult i think people are quite happy
to sit down and get table service
everything
but for the business itself that we've
we're losing probably most industries
about about
fifty percent they can lose their
capacities a lot of pubs so they really
need to be able to work at 100
capacity for many basking in the
freedoms that we've lost for so long
is plenty but the significance of
further opening for many venues
cannot be overstated ashnaharanak sky
news
in twickenham